star wars it's a horror movie right star
wars but the thing is even the edgiest
star wars movie is only rated pg-13
and you know i'm wondering what would it
look like to actually make star wars
rated r to make it authentic
to the battle experience what the heck
happens when you get shot with a laser
gun right now it's just like a little
puff like you're in power rangers but
should those things keep lasting like a
hole through your body
star wars doesn't really have a charm as
its innocent hero adventure film
but for this one video we're gonna do
something special we're gonna give you a
taste what star wars would be like if it
was rated r
[Music]
we have the power to do a what if here
what would it look like if it was made
for adults
what if we replaced the lightsabers with
like katanas
there's just earth wars man just earth
like darth vader chokes a dude you could
actually make it look painful now
veins start to bulge and like their eyes
start to go like this you know
yep oh man so this this is the darkest
moment in the entire prequel trilogy
order 66. this one could be
[Music]
oh he's so sad akira style just like
yeah just everything look he's like dumb
jedi
nothing bad's gonna have to be here oh
my goodness
what is this wait clint you don't know
about this scene no
[Music]
master skywalker he falls through a trap
door in the floor and you say ah
until
[Laughter]
over 66 feels pretty appropriate i think
so like it has it has a lot of hits
we can all come together and take a
moment from that clint's gonna do
obi-wan hitting the rocks
i'll do tall head uh getting shot up so
we all pick a moment from the kid shot
all right guys we got work cut out for
us prepare to make the jump to light
speed let's hope we don't have a burnout
tractor footage that's easy extend the
shot a little bit more to make it longer
that's easy clean plate the water out
that's easy
first challenge comes with replacing the
water with rocks but honestly that's
pretty easy too check this out
cinema 4d plus octane and a sweet rock
asset
well placed and well lit boom it's in
what do you say hey claire what's that
stuff
bouncing around the rocks well those are
limbs that i made in cinema 4d i
couldn't find obi-wan's lizard
steed beast so what i did was just got
some dinosaur
from turbo squid and chopped that up
threw some dynamics on its limbs
and gave it some initial force down to
the ground
most of the dinosaur has disappeared but
i'm filling that in with blood
and smoke and mirrors and crap
you guys have to wait to see that stay
tuned
don't touch that dial don't pull that
crank don't yank that
chain don't flush the toilet because
we'll be back
i sense a disturbance in
the force no in the internet
there's a dark side to the internet and
a light side
the only way to bring balance is through
today's sponsor
expressvpn you see without a vpn you
could fall prey to the dark side
because hackers internet providers and
cell phone providers
can just take your information and do
whatever they want with it
using a vpn like expressvpn encrypts
that information
and makes sure it's protected and safe
they've got
best in class encryption they have 7
customer support
they have server locations in over 94
countries and apps
for every device there is hope just go
to expressvpn.com
crew you can get expressvpn for just
seven dollars a month
also if you sign up for one year you get
three months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
crew you can get expressvpn and never
fall prey
to the dark side
here is the original shot it's a jedi
can't handle literally two stormtrooper
shooting at him
i wanted to make this way more violent
if you've seen akira there's that one
guy who's stealing the kid at the
beginning he gets all shot up by the
riot police i wanted to take that as my
inspiration
first off not nearly enough lasers are
being fired so i went and i cranked up
the lasers and i perfectly matched my
lasers
the lasers from the movie and the reason
they look really good is because i'm
using andrew kramer's
saber plugin andrew basically went and
made the best laser slash lightsaber
plugin
for after effects for free it's on
videocopilot.net so
if you need to do lasers or lightsabers
or whatever go check it out it has a lot
of really cool features
so use that to duplicate these lasers
and make my own
i also use the liquify tool to like have
parts of his head burst
as well as like clothing this gives me
motivation for all my blood spurts
i used uh action vfx's blood hits pack i
just have a lot of blur going on
initial frames when things are bright
and hazy and then it kind of sharpens up
as the shot goes on
so one more thing i did i did some
bullet hits we have a bullet hit on his
eye here for example and
he gets shot in the side of the head and
the way i did that is i combined the
flesh wound element from action
essentials just a flesh wound
with a blood splat and those two on top
of him
give it a pretty convincing blood sweat
oh and as a final like little touch i
put some blood splatters in the ground
i hope you enjoy a more accurate
representation of what stormtrooper
lasers would do to you
clone trooper lasers sorry difference so
i finished my shot but i was feeling
kind of hollow
and incomplete and i couldn't figure out
why until i realized it was because
i have this opportunity to do something
that i'm sure everyone has always wanted
to do
and that's to mutilate jar jar binks
so i thought what if instead of his
tongue going numb
his whole head explodes so looking at
the truck from the outside there's a few
things that you gotta do first you gotta
track the shot then you gotta create a
clean plate that goes where he is
i added him back in with some like find
edges effects and some
turbulent displace on top of that to
kind of get that electrical sort of look
on top of all of him
charge our charger beings
with something like this more is better
having a lot of different elements you
got the lightning you have the sparks
you have the
teared skin of a cloth simulation you
have the actual blood burst you have
smoke bursts it kind of just gives that
misty look so you actually have like
some vaporized
blood and then to top it off you have a
severed head beautiful how many elements
is enough elements the answer is never
no that's not you can never have enough
elements always put in
more because chances are it'll look
better when you have more contrast and
variety and visuals going into something
thing you want to be careful about is
hitting that point of just visual noise
where there's so much stuff happening
so dense every single image has so many
things going on
you want to make sure each thing that
you add is distinct
now this is an example of using just
nothing but existing video files that i
already had that i can just
throw in there a la carte but sam over
there is actually working on a custom
blood simulation
for his shot and that'll be one of a
kind i want to see that
what makes these little experiments so
great is it
opens up these opportunities for us to
explore
and learn and try out some new
techniques we've been wanting to do for
my shot i got just that i've been
experimenting with this new plugin
called x particles which allows us to
simulate fire
smoke liquids soft bodies rigid bodies
young jedi bodies
these bodies are plumb full of metal
chlorines i got to put that to work
today
he falls through a trap door in the
floor and he's here
so he's falling so fast that his body
combusts
into a million little pieces if you
actually watch the scene
where he threatens the babies with the
lightsaber it immediately cuts
to padme's apartment so we took that cue
this is probably
where he's gonna land basically i'm
gonna have the youngling hit
the glass of padme's apartment so this
is very strong glass
i'm not gonna have the glass like
shatter into pieces but i'm going to
have
the youngling explode into pieces so the
way i want to do that is using a fluid
simulation
so in order to make a fluid simulation i
need to model the environment roughly
this is my little environment here so we
have our floor area here
here's our glass so rather than actually
simulate something falling down and
exploding
i basically just have the body at the
glass and i'm using this
really rough model of like arms and legs
as
the source in which the liquid is going
to emit from i've got all this fluid
here i'm basically just saying just
go just go with from this moment because
honestly if something's falling from
that high
velocity it's going to go all over the
place basically then i'm just telling
the fluid
hey fluid i want you to have a lot of
friction you know i want it to
stick and slide a little bit now that i
have my particles
simulated here i actually have to take a
measure it basically looks at these
particles and builds a mesh around them
turns these particles into something
renderable and physical boom
hitting the glass exploding all over the
place
it's very messy now the second half the
blood is one of those cool advanced
techniques i've never messed with before
it's called making a wet map
this is really good for splatters and
stains the trail
of fluid that follows something like
this like if i had a sponge and i just
wiped it on the wall
it would leave a wet trail behind so
hence the name
wetmap these particles now are painting
residual
smearing of like some goop running down
the glass
boom man you see how that stuff is
exploding holy frick
today we are watching all of our hard
work together we
each worked on a shot and now it's time
to watch them all together
with glorious sound design i know cliff
did some v.o
that's gonna be good hey we decided to
make star wars naughty because we're all
big boys
three two one play
the fleet has moved out to fight speed
and we're preparing to
[Applause]
[Music]
oh goodness sinking in
hey keep pulling those energy binders
if your hand gets got in the beam it's
been
dude so rough
[Music]
execute order 66.
[Applause]
yes
oh my god
[Music]
don't stop shooting
bring our little girl close to the
window
i'm going down
[Music]
master skywalker there are too many of
them what are we going to do
[Music]
i'm sure he'll be all right
[Applause]
oh that was easy
bonus
that voice over honey i'm bringing our
daughter to the tower
the perverted yoga thing really wow i
was not expecting that
for all the effects we added like nick's
nick found a good scene
that was a good
yeah i cut it out above his bottom jaw
so it's just the top part of his jaw his
tongue wiggling out
so rough hey it's rated r yeah so do you
guys think george lucas is going to see
this and like squeeze it into his
special special edition this is how it
was meant to be how it was really meant
to be did you hear that he had an
extra like special edition that he's
been sitting on for years for the newest
release of
a new hope when it came out disney plus
there's actually a new edit around when
han
shoots guido greedo
[Music]
you